but don't you look good roof should be
having it looking authentic she's the
best in the whole business Ruth Carter
doing the costumes coming to work
today's like I'm going into a time warp
she has a way of completely transporting
you this is a big endeavor we dress
every single person that you see on
screen people on dates people coming and
pimps hoes you name it we had to make
rudy stand apart from everyone else and
still be in the 70s mr. Ritter we bridge
the gap with Leisure Suit we made suits
other patterns we used a lot of texture
so not only would he have the 70s look
but he would have his own seventies look
don't which I'll think of it I was like
wow she did not hold back it's a little
bit louder a little bit brighter come on
down pick me up
come on give it up for queen bee really
wanted to give lady Reed an ark we see
her in the beginning in a house dress
where she finds her husband cheating on
her at the club and then with Rudy ray
Moore she becomes a queen full-figured
in bright colors well-fed ready to be on
stage you think you could just walk up
here Jaime no with Leslie we wanted to
make sure that Dora voles look always
had something self-conscious about it he
wears this patchwork hat that matches
the jeans you know we see him in these
combinations that are all kind of
custom-made can you imagine these people
dressed like flowers and like a
botanical garden but it were broke but
they look good the guys love the 70s
clothes polyester could have a real
comeback after this that's all
[Applause]
[Music]